hello and welcome to this twitch stream
very happy to be online here for the
Evora
thematic tournament yeah this is has
been scheduled and it's going to start
in three minutes
roughly three to four minutes in order
to have some celebration for my efore
repertoire finally being released on
chasuble
probably some of you have seen it
already on my channel maybe you've
gotten it already yeah anything I might
be possible that you already already
know about it but if not it's um I think
yeah useful for you to to know anyway
we've got a tournament on our hands it's
starting in three minutes and we even
have some prizes here you save fifty
thirty twenty are the prizes generously
generously said we would fish TV she was
very generous in donating their one
hundred dollars and no you don't need a
chance of a pro subscription to get the
most out of the book videos you can
justified it is not bad to have it has
some interesting features but it is not
it's not a necessity to be pro on
chasuble I'm by the way I'm not going to
play in the tournament I'm actually
going to just do very relaxed commentary
on it yeah I'm going to check out some
interesting players going to do keep it
sing mostly yeah generously is a word
but
yeah well I basically went with what
fishie fishie said out so he donated and
therefore he set the tournament of I
also did not really recognize beforehand
that this collides with the with the
yearly as a yearly blitz going on here
on beaches and yeah maybe still some
people were joined from there and this
is a three minute tournament without
increment yeah thanks for following more
no savage it's a funny username going to
say yeah neither I did not spend $100
and again it was donated by fishy fishy
usually user here on leeches he has he
has set up many of those tournaments
very very nice of him so um no I'm going
to be in Berlin on Friday the first
round I'm going to do commentary on will
be round six and the German commentary
okay we are how to start in ten seconds
and I'm not sure who I'm going to watch
will see probably will start with some
games of the higher rated players and
then see who's leading the event so are
we going to
go with this one sexy chessmen against
fly in the sky fly in sky okay so we
have a Sicilian unsurprisingly it's one
year four we won't have anything else in
this tournament one year for has set up
as a as a mandatory what happened why
didn't move that's weird
okay okay let's go with that one then
that looks like what is that that was
some grid other coins and we have Mishka
the great playing whoa somebody I cannot
pronounce it so we transpose from pawn
structure wise into a caro-kann exchange
where ENC pawn have been traded however
a little bit weird is the kingside yeah
and we already see that black is out for
blood
you cannot now take twice H takes H
takes and I takes because of mate on h2
and if you take pawn on d5 pawn on d5
Bishop takes the open H file is also
going to be tricky yeah white goes with
g3 and that's not a movie enough to play
because of Bishop g4 which is a pretty
annoying pin no black can take on a
three take on h4 and be better not sure
how much better but quite a bit better
for sure black has basically one upon I
think after the very likely Queen to d7
maybe 20 to f6 going to g6 I would go to
the 7 probably H takes you four is not
easy to play you're opening up your king
side too much so I don't think that wide
will really take on h4 but rather go
Queen Nia could be three now that's a
tough position very difficult to play
but I think black must be four choice
why doesn't have a clear
attacking idea available maybe you can
push the apron but black will be very
quickly with Bishop f6 Ruby g8 these are
all moves that could help maybe there's
even something more more forceful okay
if I've that I'm not sure about but it
looks a little bit that looks a little
bit odd but it could be strong simply
for tactical reason sir Bishop takes f4
is a threat which was ignored our queen
takes it for okay so while can recapture
with the Queen if black takes but black
will be simply better if he does that
and takes on g3 is just a pawn for
nothing and this is comparable of course
Ruby g8 is maybe even stronger as we
should be 595 after undo this is also
good for black yeah simple flavor black
but it is good play like is just better
quite quite clearly his pawn up
currently and he's got the more
realistic attacking chances should be
aged 5 so white really going for the f7
pawn I don't know
probably not but f6 is a good move
anyway yeah hello to all of you in the
chair it gots many regulars on and I'm
happy to see that even the late time
here is not keeping people from from
joining the stream and having some good
time here we'll be watching some some
good blitz games
yeah it's a bit late but I mean I - I
spoke with the sponsor of the tournament
and he said this is a good time so we
were going for that and it's also it has
to be a time that works for me so here
we have some complications what is going
on here there are many moves possible
even Bishop e8 now is is an idea I don't
know changes please for that moment yeah
thanks for the feedback on the on the
DJ's who yeah I'm very happy that bleach
has sent that to me a while ago and it's
it's fun to to we're on stream Oh
now black disc was completely falling
apart and we're now resigned
what happened and there was certainly
white was certainly worse but he has
managed to manage to do it right
thanks for the grx okay so who is
currently near the lead Alaskan wool
warm as want to games okay and
interesting I would want to check this
quickly light like isn't is a name that
I know from from from the ICC days that
is an international master on the eyes
to see a Marten some Sunday very good I
am and I'm not sure it could be him I
think he's playing what was that outfit
opening what that there was a French I
think he plays the French yeah that that
could be him here very much and he's
winning with black like up everything
just a bit bit of a hectic time scramble
but light like has won this game quite
convincingly so what about sexy chessmen
what would have him death he is playing
i he's very high ready to play our turn
okay so let's have a look at this game
what do we have here it looks like first
glance a Sicilian but yeah it was a
Sicilian actually and here I think black
black seems to be okay
FM's on start and I take night to see
fourth is the big issue and white needs
to have something ready against this
idea and I'm not quite sure what it is
the Bishop one g7 is very strong and
yeah white chose to keep it simple in a
way I can't simply take it but still
yeah unless there is something special
going on black is going to be better
here the pawn structure is not good
white might be active enough to
compensate and be okay but he can never
be better as black structure is clearly
quite superior white is also having
slightly yeah big back rank and he now
took care of that yeah I think black
for choice here for sure the question is
how exactly how are you going to do it
you don't want to trade so much here
third route d8 sorry b8 blunders the
house and I didn't even say I thought
Quincy fire was played anyway why does
tried four count to play them and
Knoblauch gets the D file well that sets
a rotten ending
I c-can't do graph form okay Mia
watchable yeah I should probably hold
this with the activity you might turn
you might at the end be a pawn down but
you should lose why it is so so active
that it should work yes I will do the
first round of commentary in Berlin on
Friday that is at least what I'm
planning with I mean there's a little
there's a little issue they are with the
contract that the organizer sent me
because I find some parts of it a bit
strange and if they are completely weird
about it I don't know I wouldn't really
like to like to sign that contract
anyway there's something about it that
if you are taking part in the commentary
on the side that you that you that you
should not do anything for other
websites which is weird because I mean
why shouldn't I let's say make a video
for my youtube channel so I'm currently
asking and what about this yeah I
definitely want to do the odd video
about about it yeah I also find that
it's weird that they send me a contract
like five days before it's actually
happening anyway that's kind of I'm
going to do the local commentary by the
way
chessmen he had the rating favorite in
this game heavy rating favorite is going
to lose the game he's clearly lost
position wise I believe or not yeah well
it was on time definitely lose on time
they don't position as well and I'm
going to commit it for the for this for
the official or for the crowd in the in
the actual playing when you know I don't
think I will know I was definitely not
doing any commentary together with Fiona
she will
I think arrived on the 20th and I don't
think she's involved with anything they
are what like with the official
broadcast okay so what's going on here
I like save bodies which is leading the
event that's funny so not saying it's
funny but it's a funny name somehow
let's see what happens here against
Kunis Kunis puss yeah I I think the
German commentary is will be broadcasted
so if you understand German you will
probably be able to you you will you can
watch my commentary on side and actually
can use the gif you speak German
yeah the room seems crowded and noisy F
I've already experienced that okay this
is a very weird opening by wider wider
is
what's my doing it's settling himself
with the weak core non-default has no
real compensation but it's got some
activity going a little bit weird yeah I
know I'm going to do I'm going to do
commentary together with Ilya Zara
Gatzke German Grandmaster yeah for sure
who knew taxes wondering how long they
will play but they start at three and
judging from the rounds up to this point
it's going to be I mean it's it's more
of a slugfest than anything else it's
really really really sharp
yeah I think it was a very entertaining
tournament or is a very entertaining
tournament so far here white has
completely completely ruined his pawn
structure I mean that's one of the worst
porn porn structures ever yeah maybe the
the players are playing very fighting
chess because they are so much I mean if
the playing conditions are as weird as
they as they say maybe they are getting
aggressive or something okay here 93 is
a big threat so white has to do
something about it and he's clearly in
deep trouble because the pawn structure
is terrible it's like 1 2 for pawn
islands against 2 and that's terrible
yeah
Greece Oaks there's no water in the
toilet disaster this will be the the
quote from this Avenger sorry for being
irritating after
you
the toilet conditions are part of the
new reader anti-cheating agenda so you
think the water in the toilets is
somehow I've got the flag cub the
playing conditions there the water in
the toilet would be necessary for
cheating so there this is why they have
no other water I have no clue I know
something white has blunted rook and and
resigned it was a pretty clear victory
for black I think it's a tough one yeah
it's very very close very close event
Andrew sexier has a very relatively low
rating but with mm it's got a good
bullet writing though and he's won many
games I want to watch this game that's
too high rated players
Jamarcus and toy walk and we see that
those have a long history of games
they're like 100-something games
oh this line with white Yang was played
against me playing black my Dutch
Grandmaster free zone I blue and I was
checkmate at bottom of 25 and that
wasn't good one of my many losses with
the French defense
maybe toy Hawk is doing better which is
not really difficult well that was a
surprising decision to take on d3 did
they both deserve or something it looks
like yeah there are so much there play
very very good yes they both deserved
yes absolutely you can see it here
and they don't really have drawers you
don't see that and the the way the
screen is constructed of the screen is
screening stains done they have oh but
code says today you learned that kills
Oshima of beliefs that he got abducted
by aliens but that's all Newseum he has
thought that for four years yeah whitey
looks like he's completely winning at
this position he's got a huge advantage
in space and this is a bit surprising
maybe it's still a good though it isn't
d5 was a strange move why why go d5 you
just playbook c1 or something no Quincy
- maybe yes that's easy
okay so we continue and black is a black
is rook up
I actually don't find the idea that
there could be aliens so totally absurd
but I find it completely episode that
they would abduct evolution off this is
the this is the most this is the
craziest thing about it why would they
abduct some some some idiot like him
yeah that's really weird
no I'm drinking I'm drinking team so
twelve walk wonders good game and go can
go kairkhan is leading now Alaskan bull
worm is leading who is Alaskan bull worm
I'm going to follow him we want to see
more of the less can go wrong this is
green this is a green team that was the
this was the latest game I don't know we
could Houston buy unless kaboom I mean
she's actually am i could i could join
this tournament of course but I don't
want to and nobody tests I ran the thing
of some some sort of life for me I'm not
thinking about the green people are
driving around in the flying saucers or
flying around and moving in those in
those things
but you never know maybe there are
little those little green people anyway
in this game eeeh Alaskan Bruin has
actually played one of my
recommendations from the repertoire that
I have released the Scottish four nights
interesting I think white looks to be
slightly better yeah it's got this
pressure against those pawns it's
nothing much but it is quite comfortable
yeah thanks for joining briefly hony
tawks a good night that has got to leave
yeah so white has the better pawn
structure a black has those two isolated
pawns and this is something that you can
definitely win games with but you have
to be technically well-versed now for
example if white would get an ending
bishop against Knight Kenny what King
would come up up to define you better
you're just better yeah deal Iran has
all draws but they gave her exciting
yeah especially today I think drew shock
was completely winning at some point now
I Tony
okay so this is oops what happened here
what was with the game before
I'm completely irritated what happened
with the game before hmm
okay what's the draw okay so here we
have Alaskan booboo on playing more fee
one two three and more fee one two three
plays a really terrible opening it's
what you can say that night six is just
bad unless can move on by the way has
reserved so he's bucking it seems every
game you say name you more fee one two
three just quickly clicking no don't see
it anyway so let's see why it should be
better here with the space and the black
queen being offside however d5 pawn
could be could be in danger
this looks good for white down after you
six yeah exactly
after something like we need to you
should just be better with the with the
superior structure and still the black
king is rather the more unsafe the
unsafe ER King
okay after those trades
I think him we cannot really speak of a
white advantage anymore
yeah I just I think it would be it's
roughly equal I mean white has preserved
so it can easily happen that the time
who play decisive role it's not a very
exciting position black will probably
bring the king up no King to his seven
later yeah we have some GM's in the
tournament we will definitely watch some
games I was just curious what Alaskan
bull worm is doing with this good score
don't do cubits on some of the
grandmasters in short order yeah I don't
know what that is supposed to lead to
yeah black is a little bit more active
him
that's a question was my favorite chess
world champion that's actually not so
easy to say because I have always liked
a number of players and they are of
quite different times and even playing
style when I was starting out I was a
fan of fishers and also I like Karpov a
lot because cup of I never really
understood how how that work yeah how
well all of a sudden we get an advantage
out of nothing and that happened quite a
lot and then in the early 90s when I was
actually getting better doing lots of
chess training for myself
Kramnik was coming on the scene and I
always liked his player it was in fact
very enterprising even back in the day
and I was able to yeah really said
Kasparov serious problems it was very
very exciting their time and so I've got
many what's to like as far as play a lot
yes it's really not something where they
have an absolute favorite okay here it
will be about the time and why does
equal ish but he's also very quick I
mean but Murphy is also quick this is
going to be a draw position twice and
maybe they manage to get it on the board
and I guess no playing I know okay so
it'll be a draw tougher very tough okay
so and there was a mention of one GM
macro Fargo we can watch this game if we
ever see it I see it here macro Fargo is
there a name in there who is that Jose
Carlos ibera Harris probably not doing a
good pronunciation book pronunciation
I should go to chess top comment comment
on your car why would I do that
never I would talking with yourself I'm
not going to leave for some random games
anyway yeah here white is in huge
trouble
oh and then d4 was blundered oops
what's going on Wow and the Queen gets
lost and black one a very very very very
real and quick fashion let's see let's
let's watch one or more games of this
player he plays against deep nonsense
okay that's a good line
by the way against the modern it's not
what I have in my repertoire but it was
a consideration why does the playing for
very I observed that one interesting
this is playing um some setup that is
similar to to the truth away yeah with
the bishop coming to see to went having
good control like with Knight to f6 now
basically gave up on pushing e5 or f5 so
a little bit strange I think white is
actually threatening h5 now and this
makes sense that looks good
yeah g5 maybe Queenie for even f4 queen
h7 it looks dangerous her black whenever
the pawn comes to e5 and this is this
diagonal is opened up it will be
dangerous to defend us will be dangerous
to defend us the attack will be very
dangerous and tough to defend sorry my
stream is my my voice is actually fading
a little bit the time is getting closer
they they only have 30 seconds apart now
after Berserker that's also a good
success for the person who did the
berserk oh and that's a good that's a
good defense I think deep nonsense get
something traded if white now has to
take on a form that would be nice okay
it didn't do that and probably that's
very much justified
okay now Queen tej
nobody's ever saying who's
yeah while it's just a piece of him that
should should be enough t5 saying yep
and why it's to two pieces up that will
be easy an easy win okay let's see who
else is on who else is on anybody I
should qubits okay we got a new
tournament leader and toy walkers
playing sexy chessmen okay again we had
this before right what's going on here
white is an exchange up they both have
preserved okay yeah why should win this
fairly easily there is not any counter
play inside for black there's nothing
special we only think that that what
that black would hope for was the knight
on c5 but white is doubling on the D
file and so I think you should win
fairly that's a good move in context
Knight X and now White's King position
is a little bit compromised
okay I think well played a bye-bye both
on 57 now is a blunder like blundered
yeah that's that's me to come good give
me about ty Bach what about the Astana
chess was a request so let's do it
astonish yes so what's going on here
let's do a count black is an exchange of
and nothing anything nothing you know
it's just an exchange going to e8 is
there some counter play Bishop f8 no not
really
queen-to-be seven I probably will cover
everything or Queens have six
you can't go night xh7 now if you like
and maybe white should do that snatch a
pawn and get rid of the bishop as the
defender nineties h7 okay it's available
if you want to do that not so much about
the pawn but rather about getting the
defender removed yeah here Knight what
has to go back I don't know I think I
would have gone gage tonight HSM I'm not
sure that it would have helped anything
but okay
nice calculation he gets the night with
Queenie for him and now black is just a
piece of okay we're going easily okay
this is one of those cases where I think
for white playing on is entirely
pointless your position is totally lost
yeah you're going to be mated probably
and Queen eighty-five Schmidt should be
celibate to come and over it so that you
can simply safely resign you're not
going to save that ever I'm you're down
on time your position is lost
mmm just just just resign okay Estonia
is getting geek Aria as an opponent with
1800 white is a huge favorite but let's
see what exactly happens got the
philidor's that's an interesting choice
yeah Bishop to c4 I don't think that
this is actually that fantastic but okay
Isana has observed and you have to be
quick here hello - if she in this chat
I completely understand if you don't
resign immediately yeah when you're down
some material because sometimes you just
disappointed or what and you're kind of
just out of out of pure and no self hate
yeah continue for a moment but then once
you yeah once you start to think a
little bit more clearly you should
simply resign and get and to get a new
game going when you can actually score
yeah white I think is better here but
black has the extra minute and it is
always going to be tricky with the night
jumping around however here I think why
does some clearly for choice if he can
get everything coordinated nicely yeah
sometimes playing in such a thematic
tournament is it's not so bad because
you're thrown to thrown into something
to play that you usually don't play if
she says is yeah I know I know I know
that you are McDonald on the other I
just don't want to confuse people and
you usually not a need for play but it's
so bad to once in a while just do
something else and this is what a
thematic tournament does for you it for
sex you forces you to do something else
I mean you can always continue to play
completely lost positions but it doesn't
make sense since in this for the
tournament format this is the thing yeah
I hello to the truth dr. fishy fishy
again thanks for donating the prize
money it seems to be a cool adventure
oh well now Stanley has plundered the
Queen I know he doesn't sorry he didn't
this is covered yeah I was just like
oops what happened so white is
completely winning and this is something
where black should simply resign the
game it's completely it's a complete
waste of time
to continue this because you can start a
new game get new points and doesn't
happen I mean you have simply simply no
no real hope there but again I is going
to try black is going to try you know
what it's a good job here's what white
is doing is super quick it's really
super quick so there's really and
there's absolutely no chance that black
will win on time white is doing
excellent pre moves and he's going to a
rather window on time now this is
completely hopeless
Luke f7 remove yep it comes and this is
I mean white blue probably made with 20
seconds on the clock
20 seconds on the clock okay that wasn't
bad
okay back to the tournament and see
what's going on macro Fargo is playing
toy walk number one and number 17
so macro Fargo black here is better yes
it's better a lot better actually
Wow there's some Bishop c2 it was Bishop
chief to perform anyway this is a very
good position because white is totally
tied down rook d3 rook e8 those moves
look look look fine yeah d8 probably and
now you're threatening Bishop takes a
three no Bishop e3 winds upon it's just
very good and Tomac resigned that that's
a good coil and you're just totally lost
and you rather can play in the game it
makes it really make sense it's a bit
early it's a bit early maybe but it's
not a bad decision it's something you
could really really do so let's go maybe
for this game I just want to show some
people who've never seen obviously
summary so ball but what happens here
now thanks for subscribing PP RT as one
okay that's not a very exciting ending
so black is up everything and it's got
more time so I don't know why white is
continuing this okay I'm going to work
on this game and so who else is on fly
in the sky against G Marcus so that
looks like a crazy position but the
white seems like in a total totally
winning position white has a huge
tagged to the winning is too strong but
White has a huge attack and just for one
pawn how would the dead
start or the French defense okay g5 yeah
white hands of white has a great
position yeah f5 is hanging I don't know
why should have been caught there it's
still rather interesting position just
doesn't make sense to follow some ending
where somebody is losing on time and has
no material it's really not much room
for surprised at saying what happens
yeah whitey is better in this attack but
how does he actually get something out
of this probably you can somehow get the
Queen to play against the d6 pawn that
would be good okay this is a direct
approach even rube chicks and I hope
takes two fives probably a weird idea
maybe the other Knight to e5 makes sense
flying skies from the attacking player
yeah that is very likely with two six
something that's going to be quite
strong and he just he has taken on d5
and move that I was thinking about but
wasn't really sure 94 for okay whoa
where's the Queen going where is the
Claire should turn down the click sounds
yeah I can do that I can do that I
turned him down a little I think that's
okay so why does one some parts and now
with Queen check that's a really strong
Queen check black has no way to to
really interpose and okay let's go back
to the tournament macro Fargo corn
isthmus and Kitty kites GF I don't know
there are in the lead all those 30-plus
players are probably the main candidates
of winning we can have a look at this
one and this is Joseph 2013 against sexy
chessmen what's going on here it's why
does a pawn up but black has some play
that is probably coming from the topple
of variation of the Sicilian in the
dragon yeah I was right about that
this is an interesting line usually for
black but I think something went wrong
because here white is more or less upon
down for nothing maybe Bishop before now
is possible to win the Jeep on new but
exactly a queen txt to you cannot play
because the b-pawn is too dangerous and
even that is going to be quite a problem
yeah there's BC
as a threat Queen cannot take as g2
Isaiah was Czech
Bishop before b7 Queen back Queen g5
check her things like that look
dangerous at least and probably you have
Queen D for versus strong where so black
is in huge trouble um we are drawing in
on 1000 participants that would be
fantastic of course yeah and this is
also fantastic and now Queen d4 is a
good movement that's basically a double
attack and wide wins this piece so yeah
this is a question by what exactly is
black hoping for down on time no
position okay here black it may hope
form Queen g5 escutcheon I mean he hoped
for the perpetual on the king no it's
it's really time to resign it's really
no chance whatsoever but maybe he won't
get who's Bishop f5 something pushing to
e4 Bishop before bringing the king to h4
is a very simple technical win
kingi forum should win the porn yeah you
can take f4 h3 bishop reform will go
with the king of kasi on that also will
work but this is a little bit trickier
now how do you cover that that wasn't
good
I got c5 okay King c3 you got c5 then
everything is fine and white had a
technical a technical justification for
his play but that was necessary is he
fine okay that wins as well yeah
good play okay back to the tournament we
are already our 600 something
participants at school so who is on top
macro Fargo fly in sky we have sex
adjustment astonishes you know we have
the and they both berserk okay and we're
starting joining right at the very
beginning so we have a car oh that's an
interesting line by the way with h4 that
is something you can recommend and I do
recommend to to people I don't have that
in the repertoire that I have released
because I felt it is a bit too
complicated for this keep it simple
approach but it is a really good line is
h4 line if you are more into complicated
and and double-edged positions I think
white has two good chances to attack a
queen b5 or no Queen c3 is actually
better that's true and now
yeah but black has some castling issues
that this is running into b4 b5 stuff
and they couldn't cancel short if you
ask me that's very very dangerous
Estonia is doing a good job here I think
that's good to create five is strong
Queen Queen b3 we cannot trade you
cannot trade with white my next
tournament my next over the board
tournament will be in San Sebastian in
Spain in it's not a long time the 24 to
20 for the first round so we're talking
ten days yeah thanks for subscribing
cool up and I will definitely play some
one year for I'm not sure about about
about how often I really am much I look
at the opponent see what to expect and
if I like what they do against thee for
I will play before and if I I mean there
are some there are some kind of setups
where where you have to play I mean at
least I have to play something else here
if I get paid let's say against the kids
and and just thirteen year old place the
kings in yet I'm going to not play you
for yeah I'm going to play the Kings
Indian and get a good position normally
so that's that's what I did what I do
and make it it's dependent on my
opponent I'm not flying to Spain no
going by train not a big deal okay so
here black is winning it's two pawns up
and that's got the better time yep
okay.you tournament
so anybody else what about Christmas
we haven't Konyaspor what is that that's
a very weird position I have to count
first yet Black is an exchange down know
what's got two pieces for the rook and
White's King is completely completely
completely wrecked but how does black
window I mean g5 looks normal
threatening Bishop takes f4 but there's
a check on the eighth-ranked I think it
should still work
why isn't you just playing g5 well as
does he have a quicker win Bishop takes
therefore maybe on am I missing
something
it looks like a complete when you queen
Queen takes bishop f1 q h5 mate I'm
happy with the view count got 170
viewers it's really really excellent so
where's the mate
yeah Bishop Jake's F form King age 3 and
where's the mate you should give five no
hmm okay yeah he just basically says
there is no check and Queen eighty-three
meters unavoidable soken Disco's resides
very clear window macro Fargo I'm sorry
I didn't want to do that there was a
real miss click let's go back here what
about this guy [ __ ] kicker TFM let's see
he's on there doing a good job and what
is that that looks weird you're trying
to guess the titles in the book so it's
going to be that would be easier Here I
am you know but I don't do that okay so
what's going on here why does a piece
down and for nothing right
yeah like it's just a pizza there was a
weird opening worldwide
it's not super exciting and wise has
preserved and it's just just down a
piece yeah there's nothing going on here
you know just takes on d4 Knight d6 and
trade down everything that also works
night she sings next that's nice
actually
it's no medium I don't see you made it's
close though and you probably should
just drop back 96 and that's it yeah
okay
wow you continuous oh that's useless you
know this is what I don't understand you
know you have absolutely no chance
whatsoever with black and white and why
do you continue yeah anyway I'm going
back there and let's see what is still
going on
macro fog well I think he did a good job
so far what is that black is its equal
ish but black has I mean in terms of
material but black has an excellent
control and those pieces here excellent
that looks like some French defense gone
wrong for Hawk and it wasn't it it
actually wasn't so University 386 okay
that's on paint yeah black is really
putting pressure on white and age three
is attacked
a three is also a checked so there was
already something something something
lost yeah that's a good choice say you
you just win this okay mmm-hmm
it does not really help you
yeah you should definitely cover the
main tanja seven but black will do that
I just wonder why and wonder how what
defended this quite well by the way if
you want my opinion about the let the
London system which is currently
discussed I mean the thing is this is
one of those openings that has a really
really boring reputation and it is not
entirely unjustified because many people
play it actually played in a boring way
it's a nice shot by the way bishop g3
pawn takes Bishop rook e2 will win there
very nicely done many many people are
play it in a very boring way but you can
actually play it in a more enterprising
style and then I don't think it is that
boring yeah but yeah in Germany we
usually call it like the old people's
opening or something and yeah and it is
it is a little bit boring if somebody
plays it who has really no ambition but
if there is some ambition nothing is
particularly wrong with it okay that was
some kind of Sicilian
hey well Sicilian was g6 yeah
[Music]
invaded it really depends what your what
you're doing with the opening so if you
play you can play something that looks
completely boring but you can still try
to do things with it
I mean in my in that if for repertoire
that I have released I have to exchange
French and this is somewhat
controversial people seem to hate this
choice but I don't really think that
black equalizer said easily I mean I
understand it's not going to lead to
sparkling attacking games every other
time but I've tried it in all kinds of
type controls and they keep winning
easily with the French exchange very
easily in fact because black players
often have no clue they think they can
play whatever crap and it's not the case
you have to really know something or
they play something over ambitiously and
just get made it or so it also happens
yeah here black is in trouble I think
King takes Queen takes d5 chick looks
bad
yeah in the exchange French if you
Castle queenside yeah that is not really
happening if white plays well you know
okay after four that's a good'n that's a
that's a tricky reply not not bad at all
I'm going to take okay well why can't
you just take your five
why can't you just take you five what am
i overlooking I could overlook something
look see - probably I just look see -
ization not very quickly uh technically
that is an issue that King is so in some
some crossfire
they cannot cancel either side and
currently black is threatening to take
and take and it's not easy at all
queen f2 was played yet again black is
not going to ever cast them long in the
French exchange if white plays it
properly
you simply cannot do it yeah I think
here Luke takes the two should just be
or look at for I don't know they both
look great it looks like white is
getting a beating him yeah rook takes f4
no critically fibers check okay I'm
sorry
Queen if five is just one check him they
have that just one check and the end we
like a straightening Luke Jerry takes
the two mate made next don't really see
a move
no and black is winning this nice one
there is no check queen g2 mate oops
I'm not clicking this correctly I did
not want to go into the analysis of you
I'm sorry about that let's go back to
the tournament fly in sky is leading
okay okay where is the game with flying
sky this one I'm playing at the spring
of 2000 that's probably helpful and he
berserk okay so wipe now why she has a
strong attack ef6 saucers on the cards I
mean one thing you have to see is that
with the e4 automatic tournament one
thing is an issue if you are not a four
player you have a slight disadvantage
thanks for the great feedback mrs.
Milton
okay now black is trying for some for
some desperate counter-attack but it
shouldn't work there's just like one
check of 93 and this is not going to be
enough interesting future chess game
asked if you should switch from the news
or to the Greenfeld hmm it depends I
mean both are good openings but the
names oh and the roofers are really
quite different so you have to really
make up your mind if you have problems
against the Catalan
well that's you're not a known but there
are a number of lines that are quite
okay so I wouldn't be so desperate there
just because you have a Catalan problem
I'd say to learn the full to learn the
full Greenfeld but Rafael is of course a
good opening maybe I should do a green
card repertoire once it could be
interesting it's the only main main line
opening that I had never played it over
the gorgeous sorry I keep clicking
analysis what that is really bit stupid
of me okay and we have flying sky was
macro fog Oh flying skies leading this
lot by by far the news oh is in
comparison to the Grune felt in opening
that is less dependent on on concrete
lines of knowledge of concrete lines in
the names Oh quite often you can get by
with general concepts if you know
basically where the pieces belong to put
it in one sentence then you're going to
be oftentimes able to get by in the
names Oh with the groom fell this is not
impossible you have to learn many lines
by heart and if you don't remember them
depending on your level of opposition
you can just lose outside like right out
of the opening and this is something
that here you have to take into account
it depends on the level of your position
yeah some of the chat is cut but I have
to place my video somewhere on the
webcam the name is always very flexible
and it is something that I think has a
very good balance between let's say the
effort you need to invest and quality of
the position however the names o is
oftentimes not the issue anyway but it
is rather the Catalan or the choice
against 393 the nihms oh no splash would
gladly take but it's also easy to find
something to like against the Catalan or
yeah what you want you partner the limbs
with by the way in this game
macro Fargo tries to break through in
the center with pins
looks dangerous
yeah with the green felt what you
definitely will get as more open
positions and it's for many people
really a good quality and a good selling
point them the reason why I never played
the green father simply that on the
level that I oftentimes play like the
leaky games against AIIMS and GM's I
often times fear that they would didn't
get a concrete preparation in and then I
need to know all the things in the green
file and I have a hard time memorizing
everything plus oftentimes all the makes
a force good now I have there's a back
wing made room takes it for Sweeney I
was good for that
yeah well you need to calculate a lot in
the green card it's a it's an opening we
are correct calculation is paramount and
this is not really the best part of my
game this is why I never really
seriously considered to play the green
fell but it is an excellent opening
definitely a very good point about us it
that you have no structure weaknesses no
bad pieces or very very nice okay here
white should win I'm not sure what
currently the current good book on the
Brune felt is there were the average
books they were of course very very
detailed but they're already a couple of
years old now yeah I'm not so sure
there's a book by Del shape and I guess
that is also a couple of years old but
it's a little bit more accessible it's
not as full of variations as the arab
book you can also go with the video
series by Peter Saville on chest
before but this is going to be really
really difficult unless you're already
let's say of them all so it's it's so
detailed and it's so quickly like then
there's just our eldest son and this one
and another move and it's so so quick
that I basically had to stop because I
couldn't really follow what you were
saying but it is something oh oh and
black wins all of a sudden that's weird
I managed to go go back correctly so fly
in sky is probably closer penguin ahem
is he playing actually see playing no I
don't think so
I'll have a look but 781 participants
maybe we get some more because the the
the yearly blitz is over
yeah of course you can pause the video
yes with this video but yeah I'm just
saying it's high level it's really high
level so let's go flight and sky okay
here sacrificed on g5 here I don't think
that's supposed to work here that early
on I don't know okay it's real it's just
so you can try all kinds of things like
of a straw that's funny
why would why take a draw and maybe he
feels like he's east or not I mean he
did this quite willingly not so bit bit
odd but I think white is probably in
good shape nice got two points for two
points and look for the two minor pieces
and the minor pieces are not very strong
currently if you check the bishop ends
right
now you can definitely use fiddler
series for your goon felt plans I'm just
saying be prepared it's very very very
very high level which is lagging I don't
know
the problem is is not like if a serious
like next witness it's not about if he
knows his stuff he knows his stuff the
question is is it usable this is the
thing yeah I mean there are there are
things that are maybe nice and people
are experts and everything but it is
tough to use you know if you've looked
at some of the GM repertoire books by
quality chairs you know that there are
excellently researched but are you
really going to learn that are you going
to really look at the 3,000 pages that
cutroni assess written on the King's
Indian I don't know I know
Annika
sometimes less is more you know because
you can actually handle it this is
sometimes a problem you have too much
information and this is something that
is the challenge with the Grune fell
because you can yeah you can it's very
difficult to make it easy to understand
so something like what I try to do and I
keep it simple one year for keep it
simple Greenfeld you know who I have no
clue if that is possible I mean there's
this book the easiest group out or
something
by they are seven ogress that I already
mentioned they are doing it quite well
but it's so difficult
okay so what is happening in this game
by the way just have a look
a very tough position I mean just the
group threat have more theory than the
Sicilian um-hmm
that's a tough call it depends on the
Sicilian it has definitely more Theory
to learn then let's say I'd say e six a
six Sicilian like the con variation or
something or if you play a no
accelerated dragon that's also less
theory but if you go
especially cough neither off dragon yeah
it has worn its comparable maybe we're
gonna test less sidelines and Sicilian
you also have to know all the all the
smaller lines yeah the C threes and we
should be fives and we should be five is
not a small lie anymore
but tell me you know there are many
deviations in the Greenfeld deviations
are the London and stuff like that
understanding the goon felt by Jonathan
Ralston is of course the ultimate wound
felt classic it's probably actually
difficult to get because it's such a
classic now it just almost twenty years
old I think it's from 1999 or 2000 and
you cannot really use it anymore on the
move by move base because so many things
have definitely changed but it is an
excellent book Rosen actually is I think
the inventor of giving names to pawns
not Simon Williams he called the D pawn
dare royal and Delroy the D pawn came
you tournament
fly in sky is leading yeah he's doing a
good job so here we've got a declined
immoral gambit and black is already
quite okay it looks like a very very
decent decent position for black
what a horrible name who's got a
horrible name yeah white development is
fine but like I think has an easy game
we should reform it's a little bit
underdeveloped yeah I mean the night of
book that is twenty years old
I mean it's totally clear that people
don't don't know that much theory so you
can say you can use something older but
neither of twenty years or book I
wouldn't do it I mean it really I mean
you get to the argument if you are let's
say on a level that you're good enough
that that playing the night off make
some sense you know I mean you're not
going to be rated 1400 and study the
night or if you have other things on
your plate if you are on a level that
studying and opening that night off
makes sense then the book is taught
because people will play lines that
back-in-the-day
weren't really relevant like yeah on the
six move from yeah h3 for example is
such as a line that really needs some
yeah need some study or some Bishop III
details have changed so much over the
years it could happen that you get
quickly something that you have never
seen from this from that book so here
I'm like why it's sort of Bishop d6
what's going on here why does winning
the exchange share on b8 or like that
all right or like that and that's not a
real compensation here for black I guess
I'm not sure about the state of the drag
a door for dragendorff so I don't know
what the current state of theory is that
wasn't interesting lines and years ago
but I don't know how it is currently the
chiyan ink was slapped with black I
don't think there's anything wrong about
it it is still played quite frequently
white is an exchanger but it is so quite
complicated flying the sky fly in sky is
a good defender yes if you go premium on
chest twenty-fourths filler video is
included yes are all the videos so this
is um the video archive is it's quite
nice and it's really quite good value I
thank you
yeah now I think white has it completely
under control he's got this pawn
structure completely demolished and he
Bishop c4 mini-me to trade the bishop
yes yeah it looks very nice
now the g7 bishop is pretty bad
very nice more feeble witness that looks
like a pretty clean win from him yeah
and resigned so back to the tournament
so paying this pang pang when actually
playing let's check this no only penguin
in black okay it would be fun so who's
going to win it he's leading by a couple
of points but Joseph yes is is close so
one of those five or six people will do
it okay so let's go flying sky against
wasted years we've got a berserk by
flying sky it's not even dashing out to
move that quickly g4 is an interesting
move now you see those early g-force all
over the place
and I'm not going to play after the
tournament yeah that's one a.m. and I
have to have to take get some sleep
absolutely the twitch streams are a
little bit of a problem for me sometimes
actually because I will I usually start
the match 11 German time and if I do
like 2 hours it's 1 a.m. and then it's
getting if I do a stream after 1 a.m. it
takes 1 hour a little bit longer till I
actually can sleep I cannot just like
and they get to bed and sleep and this
is so late that my sleeping pattern is
completely completely wrong at the
moment and this is not good in the
normal run I have to think about this I
would really like to stream at some
other time the pinko is it a sound
defense yeah I guess so I mean it's
difficult it's difficult I think to
maintain as as your own opening SEO
sorry as you are only opening if you
play on a very very high level like the
GM level because there are just so many
lines that what could could throw at you
and then try some concrete preparation
so it's it's difficult I think for
perform strong GM's to play all the time
but on a normal level yeah on a ai' MGM
level no problem at all
I don't think you have to I mean if you
want to do it at the 2500 player of the
time off on my level you have to really
do lots of work but it's a fantastic
opening on on any sort of master level
Club
because you get so much active plane
yeah I look at the red defenses in my
ear for repertoire I mean I'm not
looking at the book because well just
about the pieces and win but I quickly
look at the ovens and names of each
defenses yeah I do
I mean it's it's kind of part of part of
the job but I haven't looked at g5 that
would be the book yeah flying sky is
going to win this quite easily and this
is talking like yeah black resigned back
to the tournament it looks like I mean
this is remarkable
yeah Joseph he has gone eight so many
games and really lots of games and they
play against one another and we should
probably have a look there yeah the
books behind me are almost all about um
almost all about chess but like ninety
percent roughly and I'm not sure I have
a couple of hundred books maybe two or
three hundred you know I have sold a lot
because I just felt I don't need them
all and and that I tend to sell some
books after a while because if you are
just sitting then yeah just collecting
dust doesn't make much sense yeah I was
thinking of doing streets actually not
at least these days these some times
time of day but rather earlier but I'm
not really sure those times are simply
not great for most people if I would do
a stream best for me would be to stream
at let's say four or five German time
but that is going to be bad for the
Europeans because they are oftentimes at
work
the US yeah whatever you're very like us
Asia Asia which would be good but us for
example would be bad yeah all the times
my rating is roughly two thousand four
hundred thirty I'm probably not I mean
if I do some middlegame stuff I would do
it in form of a twitch stream that's
going to be on YouTube like I would set
up a stream at a specific time and say
okay we'll do like one hour of
middlegame analysis and that I could put
onto YouTube that's something that I
would think about or I thought about but
the problem is really the the scheduling
of the streams because those late
streams as I mentioned they mess up my
sleeping pattern quite a lot and I have
to think about this when what would be a
good time also for for for any other
stream because I don't think I could do
that in the long run have those late
have those late streams like two or
three times a week I would like to do it
because I enjoy the streaming itself the
problem is simply the time of day okay
so what happens here flying sky playing
astonishes macro Fargo is also close but
do they have what has a very nice ending
yeah yeah with the bishop pair
we've got equal points and always
blunders before okay
my dad was nice before he blundered it
would he got f5 in K so white is still
better him
I don't think Oslo you're asking how to
improve the depths of calculation and
you either well I don't know you but my
experience as a chess teacher is people
have no problem
calculating deeply because mostly you
don't need to calculate deeply you need
to calculate two or three movers right I
mean if you want an advice how to get to
2,000 just to blunder pieces and then
you have it almost and this is what
people mostly do they make some pretty
short calculation errors or they it's
not like blundering stuff but like
overlooking something on the very next
move it's not like here had this line
and it was ten moves deep and I couldn't
see move nine that's not happening
that's simply not what happens to people
what happens is I played this move then
my opponent played Knight to f5 and I
never looked at that and this is exactly
what happens they miss the direct reply
or they when it's their turn they have a
great opportunity that they can play and
they don't even see this move as a
potential candidate and this is where
our points get lost not by calculation
errors on move five or so this is of
course sometimes important if you let's
say you are in a King and pawn ending at
you have to check the next couple of
moves okay you should be able to do that
but most of the mistakes are happening
like right in the position in front of
you where you don't see a potential
candidate or you don't see a reply that
is what happens most of the time and not
something deep down or they they see
okay I have this idea they have the
right idea what to do but then they
screw up the line at the very beginning
like I knew that there would be a fork
something and then the tactics are not
pieced together correctly well it's not
so much about visual
position five moves ahead you really
have to calculate five moves ahead
okay so let's click on this game and
okay this is a that's something that I
know what at least middle game was that
Amarok C point and what happens all of
the time that people see you know that
that that sets of long day why does
winning material now a three is a nice
move but the bishop wants in three and
it's dependent here on the Queen and the
Queen cannot go anywhere and rook
everyoneís even the queen is lost it was
a plate
okay Queen f6 also very strong the maroc
C bind is a line in the Sicilian that is
characterized by the sponsor
I'm not calculating deeply I'm not much
of a calculator so flying sky six
adjustment that is closer those two
maybe Joseph are in the hunt let's click
on one of those if you I think if you're
stuck on the rating of roughly one
thousand there's a really nice video
series if you want something quick and
and really AM helpful there's a good
video series by John Bartholomew on his
YouTube channel yeah uh I think it's
called chess fundamentals if I'm if I'm
correct and people will know it so they
will correct me if I'm doing this wrong
this is always pointed out but many
people has a really good resource for
some concepts that will help you better
how to select moves
and how to get a better grip for
systematics in the game however it is
very much important that you play games
and play games on somewhat longer time
control don't play bullet that doesn't
help play something that is at least at
least blitz met a longer time yeah I
always recommend 15 minutes a table like
15 minutes and a slow increment a small
increment maybe so that you can actually
play out the endings that I think is
helpful and you get the games afterwards
this is important I don't think I
haven't done videos of that type really
Oh black resigned because mate oops
that's one that's going to be very close
call but it is not helpful for
visualization the only thing that you
can it's it's about doing patterns that
you know but I don't don't really see
much in terms of does it help yeah look
at the games I mean analyze your games
try to find out where you really went
wrong that is something that an engine
can help you with one better even if you
have a have a chest teacher that could
help you or the friend who is a stronger
player or clock made or something like
that
okay so fly in sky is playing a line
that is just really bad but it's not
used by toy walk c3 is a lot better
I mean if you just play the games and
don't really find out where you went
wrong let's say it is not as helpful as
really trying to figure out where
potential improvement is so here black
is okay now therefore is is the annoying
night before is annoying I think black
would be happy here nothing special but
I mean you never calculate in a bullet
game just very very rudimentary yeah
sometimes you do calculate something
very small variation when you but mostly
it's just P move business yeah you black
is a little bit better he's got the D
file and a bit more activity going but
why does of course quite quite solid
yeah cards recommends nine hours of
sleep every night okay
this is also really dependent on on your
individual let's say house your own
everybody's different it's what I'm
trying to say you know I haven't slept
nine hours in a night know maybe for 30
years yeah I cannot do that but you have
to get some sleep at least it doesn't
doesn't work if you just have three or
four hours
so here toy rock has gotten counterplay
and more than their problem yeah black
now has to look for the sound there
twenty-five hours per night that sounds
good
I get like six hours on average maybe
asleep six maybe seven fun but it's it
doesn't really it's not easy I mean you
have to get everything kind of organized
them if you look at my schedule I have
got a the first lesson I have got when
the student is tomorrow at 10:00 a.m. so
that's in nine hours 20 minutes and how
exactly is that going to work you have
to prepare the lesson a little bit if I
haven't done so before and in this case
I haven't done so I have to maybe have
some small breakfast the shower and so
on how much our should I get yeah if I'm
streaming to one now and somebody asked
me if I would stream a little bit more
if I do it to two or three am that
that's that terrible for sleeping
pattern anyway this is looking like a
toy box tooling this on time simply and
like um like a can of course continue
here it is a draw of course objectively
but it's not like winning on time and
some dead position you have at least
some okay now now it's a very close very
close now what might manage yes you
managed okay and this is it this is
really a drop oh why
what are you can you can set one up yes
okay so very tough by flying sky yeah
you can set up and made sorry
I became you can set up a maid from here
you gentlemen
okay
so flying sky leading about four points
ahead of sexy chessmen okay we are we
are on 884 players not bad
Oh somebody's now someone someone that's
using Microsoft edge okay
oh my and then he said somehow said that
this the business side wasn't working
too well I actually had to use Microsoft
edge today there was really a really bad
day yeah yeah had to use Microsoft
Microsoft browser today and it was
really weird yeah like what is that even
but I had to use it there was no way
around it
there was a software that I need to use
for my Texas somehow and that requires
that runs in the browser and you have to
use Microsoft edge for some wacky
reasons I have no idea why but they
require you to do so so I had to use
Microsoft edge which is kind of funny
exactly it's about if you do the Texas
that's a little bit about data security
and exactly why would you use Microsoft
which is pretty much clear that clearly
the most unsafe possible browser that
you could use okay here Hawk 20 is faced
with the Bishop f5 threat and yeah
blacks position is pretty bad I wonder
if he's able to to hold for the next
couple of moves
yes they they require you to use
Microsoft edge I was also surprised to
see that what he said we had window
opening and then then it's Microsoft
edge what the crap is that and okay I
had to use it anyway let's not go there
that's actually quite complicated and
ot3 I made sorry like a completely
overlooked as a main so yeah we need
form to fly in sky keep pressing the
wrong button there yeah that's really
not great so it looks like flying in sky
is going to do it macro Fargo is the
only one that is close let's have a look
here what macro Fargo is doing what is
that it looks does look like an e for
opening my brother Kings Indian attack
I'm not sure how bad crocus I mean of
course it is a Google product but as far
as I know IT security people are not so
much against using Chrome but I mean I'm
not really an expert
yeah blacks position strategically isn't
so bad but you know b7 hangs Bishop d5
check it looks quite dangerous Bishop t5
check was pretty strong by the way it
wasn't played it's not an easy position
to play if you are working with black oh
the rook has no squares it's nice one
okay good move here Bishop d5 wins the
Queen nice one by black and white is
probably residing this it's a good win
for macro Fargo
okay that's close yeah Micro Fargo let's
have a look again got some it was a
weird French line with the should be
three or three okay yeah I think the
Apple browser Safari I think they they
okay I think they used this name already
before they started that whole life
thing I mean when was the iMac
introduced and we're talking
what kind of years that 1998 or
something I'm not sure 1997 and I think
they had Safari before not completely
sure but I think they had something
should why should win some stuff here in
this game he didn't I'm funny black
desert though okay that second place
again third place that stuff and when we
have to see there are the money prices
and only only the first three gets
something okay this is a position that
white cannot lose by the way position
wise yeah you just build you can just
set up a fortress and nothing happens
age three and then why could be five
okay I see it's blitz but so yeah okay
it's still wrong it's wrong maybe and
now the bishop can come around maybe
White was playing for win that's
possible I mean the draw might might not
just might just not be enough a 696
check as a good shotgun yeah okay
interesting and it's really trying hard
to to set some problems for G Marcus
deep-ando tough one
yeah that looks good and now March the e
pawn yeah why'd wins that was a good
good a good job yeah are you winning is
that so easy the pawns are dangerous oh
that's not a win
you're not stopping this that's crazy
yeah like winds and 12 seconds is plenty
for a good bullet / let's play yeah okay
that's easy so Jay Markus is trading
flying the sky fly in sky somewhere I
always want to say the sky okay let's
have a look at the tournament leader
he's a pawn down in this position for
nothing basically the depth that should
be very good winning chances for
morpheme it's also fairly simple to play
this position so you should just advance
the Queen side and first centralize and
then advance the Queen side should be
very very promising King can even go up
to d4 if possible you know some befall
okay that is also not a bad idea simply
block everything and now you should get
this in motion c5 maybe before moves
like that so before and black resigned
okay wow you rather wants to get a new
game and it seems so that's really
really that's really really tough year
1878 77 some very close call the whole
tournament very nice
okay so um what's going on never look at
that it's really nice if flying sky uses
that completely incorrect opening this
one and people don't don't use it anyway
it's it's blitz chess so let's see what
happens here both both observing what do
we have here white is a lot better
d6 coming adapt it's very very dangerous
to put it mildly but isn't that hanging
her than the bishop but he's 78 okay and
now they resigned early on really tough
really tough him Morpheus Morphy playing
I'm sorry
the White has managed to really close
the position down yeah that must have
been some what was that Cairo to Knights
yeah looks like it a super close
position against morphine it's tough
actually for black you don't have a porn
giver and yeah and I wanted to say maybe
you have to do this at some point to
make sure that something opens up the
position otherwise could be completely
clocked down and then then white will
storm you on the queenside b3 yes yeah I
tend to like black now he's got all the
activity ob8 you should behave Drive
yeah it's two points but I think White's
pieces don't look that great maybe white
can somehow reorganize but it looks
difficult
you know Bishop and idea they are just
sitting him they don't do much maybe
bring this okay maybe black should even
consider to take at some point then take
these three you know 93 494 that is a
breakthrough yeah white is pretty much
busted I guess but I can still hang on
okay now he gives up the exchange and
black has easy Queen d2 things like that
but yeah that doesn't win that easily
this is probably even better yeah try to
get to take h4 look III know Queen takes
h4 hands good or Bishop c4 it's more
than one good line but your black is on
30 seconds so why the certainly trying
to hang on
23
black should win only this is the kind
of stuff that I tend to screw up here
with black yeah getting mated on g7 or
something completely idiotic Queen d6
major or this one okay so a good win ear
for morpheme and it's just one point and
they play they play against one another
so this is this is for the marbles yeah
and Morpheus to win but he's not going
to do it yeah time was
Blackduck clients draw it wants to play
it out so probably if black huh I just
have to understand that I think it's
more interesting they will they will not
finish the game probably can actually
Joseph overtake them can Joseph overtake
them except the more interesting game
help me out here if Joseph wins but he's
got the same time problem I wonder Muffy
is not playing really quickly this is
what I'm wondering about I would play as
quickly as possible and try to somehow
do something but probably it's it's not
really useful anyway I mean black can
run the clock down I think
[Music]
so flying sky should win this right
there right there
macro Fargo with a quick wind they
actually make a draw he had 12 oak and
microfiber at just one point I mean this
is super super oh what's happened what
happened did they make a draw Morpheus
leading now Jose was winning you same no
it really is not anymore
what happened okay so this is not really
important anymore think it's over
so Morpheus wanted at the very very end
very nice catching flying sky at the
very last moment interesting I mean I
never really understood what what would
work Syria how would why does more free
wind because of lower game Condor it's
the game count decisive there at the
only at 26 plane and flying sky at 31
anyway congratulations to Morphy one two
three flying sky and macro Fargo for the
for taking the first three places we had
to 940 participants at the end and that
is really nice turnout performance
counts okay that makes some sense okay
performance interesting okay so I had to
type some stuff and thank to all the
players and thank the truth doctor again
for math or fishy fishy here in on
dishes for sponsoring the tournament I
think it was a great event it was much
fun to do just commentary and not play
it's a bit more relaxing and really what
I preferred to do at least for tonight
at have done some some other streams
before okay thanks a lot
to all of you I'll be back soon with a
stream I'm not yet sure
however when exactly I'm going to leave
for Berlin on Friday and maybe I can do
something from Berlin but you know this
is tough to tell what the wireless can
do in the hotel and so on things like
that I'm sure so I hope that it will
work out but I cannot guarantee it so
not sure if there will be a
on Monday as I usually do um yeah okay
thanks to all of you I'll be back
bye-bye
you